foreign
Stacy's in Shreveport Louisiana hi Stacy
welcome to the Ramsey Show
Dave at
my call I'm a little nervous no problem
never lost a patient how can we help
I was 18 he's 52 now that's precious and
he's
Set Card well we don't use any card at
all now but he hasn't used that card for
many many many years but he still pays a
250 annual fee to keep the card
and right now I've we're like turning no
more credit cards anymore at all I've
convinced him he he was a credit card
user I'm not and um I'm saying that we
shouldn't pay this annual fee we just
shouldn't have that credit card at all
and he just is in total disagreement
because he says his credit Will tank if
we do that
so that's why I'm asking you he's still
you he doesn't use the card he doesn't
use no no he had three other cards that
he was using but now we're not using it
as of this weekend so you're not
borrowing any money anywhere
ever
well we have debt oh okay
well yeah we have that let me help you
an American Express card that you don't
use does not affect your credit
it only affects your credit if you use
it
he says if he if he shuts that card down
he's trying to pay this annual fee it's
going to tank his credit he's wrong okay
he's mathematically wrong it's not it's
not a philosophy mechanically the way
the algorithm is used at FICO to create
a credit score it has to do with
activity if you have zero activity on
your accounts you don't have a credit
score
it's based on activity
and so it says so if he if he puts it in
the drawer and never gets it out and
pays 250 it's not helping nor hurting
his credit and one not one iota
it just does it's not how it works
I guess he said that since you've had it
since you
mean it doesn't matter is it a pet or a
card
it's a pet at this point it's largely
emotional I remember getting rid of my
blankie when I turned into an adult and
he needs to do the same that's all this
is it's just a blankie at this point and
it's special to him because it you walk
with him through all the seasons of life
but if he was the first person that told
him he was an adult
it was his first love
yeah well and he thinks that all of all
of her kids should get a credit card
when they turn 18 to get their credit
going well let's talk let's talk about
that for a second because that I think
that's the core issue not whether you
keep a stupid American Express card for
250 and don't use it which is irrelevant
but so the bottom line is he still
believes that being in debt is the best
way to live your life and to prosper
no no
no no there's no other reason he needs
to be confronted on this because there's
no other reason to build your credit
you don't need credit
unless you're going to borrow money
yeah and I think that we'll see we might
well we have a mortgage right now and he
works in Shreveport I actually live well
we live about an hour and a half away
but an hour and 20 minutes away so we
rent an apartment in Shreveport as well
so we had talked about buying something
like a little town home there because
his kids live
in Shreveport so this is our second
marriage so you don't have two mortgages
so you would go so you don't now we're
renting and we want to preserve our
credits so that we can go into debt and
we want our kids to get a debt go into
debt so that they can get into debt so
that why so they can build their scores
so they can get into debt why would they
build their score because we could build
our score and we if we're in debt we can
build our score and then we can go into
debt
this whole FICO thing is a dog chasing
its tail
okay it's designed for the banks by the
Banks to prosper only the banks
so if you're not going to go into debt
if you're not going to teach your kids
to go get a car loan if you're not going
to teach your kids that debt is a
survival mechanism because see your FICO
score is a has zero indication of your
net worth
I can hand you a million dollars today
it does not change your stupid credit
score one iota
okay your income could go to a million
dollars a year it does not change your
credit score it is not an indicator of
Financial Health it's an indicator of
how much you play kissy face with the
bank
so if they want to buy a house and they
had zero credit score I think you did
that George uh you know what it's the
very first video that launched on my
YouTube channel today Stacy you can't I
mean now it's not even a pitch but it's
right there you got to go pull up George
Campbell on YouTube and you and your
husband watch it tonight and then send
it to the kids you don't need a credit
score to buy a house
even if you're borrowing money even if
you're borrowing money it's called
manual underwriting I'll walk you
through it in that video on the YouTube
channel but it's real simple and I did
it myself once you're out of debt about
six to 12 months later the credit score
disappears you close all the accounts
and then you go through this process you
need a good down payment you need to
have your income you need to have your
W-2s a little more paperwork but it
really didn't break my back and I got a
great interest rate because I had a good
down payment on a 15-year fixed rate I
recommend your kids do the same if they
want to build wealth
two in debt hanging on to their blankie
it's up to them it's up to them
I mean but he did ask
ask the bank but ask some and he asked
the financial person at the place he
works at the car dealership he works at
and she said do not get rid of it I mean
she she said your your credit score will
go way down don't do it it's worth the
50 points on your credit score to pay
250 a year and I totally disagreed
but I said well I'm going to ask Dave
Ramsey I'm going to call David do some
of your own research I mean I can just
tell you the algorithm on the way the
the way FICO Works we've been trashing
FICO for years they would have come back
and haunted Us by now if we weren't
telling the truth goes to FICO yeah it's
uh don't don't worship at the altar of
the great FICO and a finance manager to
car dealerships just a dumb Banker I
mean that's all they couldn't get a job
at a bank their incentive and motive is
to get you into debt and keep you in
debt that's how they might do this deal
with people in debt all day long
but they just want you in debt they lost
hope a long time ago all the time and so
yeah they worship at the altar of the
FICO so a 40-point move a two two-point
move on a FICO scares them to death
because they Worship the Great FICO when
you have a zero FICO score and you pay
cash
you um
don't worship there anymore this is the
Ramsey Show